foreign
non-traditional
values that the military has never cared
about and implementing them in and
distracting from the true purpose of the
military which is to protect the people
who need protection
prioritizing being woke and we can't
actually protect the majority of
American people and we can't protect
their rights and we can't protect
anything for them
what's the point of you know having a
military I just don't you know I just
wouldn't consider serving for that
purpose
[Music]
my name is Aiden Gilbert I'm 18 years
old and I'm from San Diego California
my dad was a marine officer growing up I
had considered joining the military my
my opinion on it was it was something
that you know a man of Honor would would
do to Serve and Protect his country
and Serve and Protect those values that
were set and that existed back then but
I think things are a little bit
different now
I would say my opinion changed uh in my
late teen years in high school
the left has kind of
successfully eroded patriotism
by controlling everything like a
helicopter parent for example the
illegal speech codes and with genders
embracing Marxism
celebrating satanic themes and music and
Hollywood and literally spitting on God
and it just angers me seeing our
president as the conductor of that
Symphony of sewage
when us youth when we hear the word
pride we're now instinctively we're
programmed to instinctively think of the
rainbow flag whereas the generations
before me when they heard the word pride
they thought of the American flag
now that's to the left that's considered
offensive and we should burn it or
remake it along with the national anthem
and the Pledge of Allegiance and to be
honest I'm I'm really just not moved to
serve a commander-in-chief who seems to
Value the rainbow flag over the American
flag welcome to the 12th annual
Department of Defense pride month
celebration the diversity Equity
inclusion using the right pronouns is a
really simple way to affirm someone's
identity instead of saying something
like hey guys you can say hey everyone
or hey team that video
uh specifically I think was the start of
you know seeing the the military start
to go down a different path
I think I would rather tiptoe around
literal landmines than have to tiptoe
around people's pronouns and I would
much rather train to defeat our enemies
and protect our countrymen my countrymen
rather than trained to avoid offending
protected classes
people that I saw in the military were
pretty similar to me men or women who
want to serve their countrymen and
protect their values and just protect
the country and you know usually they're
they're very ambitious and hard-working
people I think now that that's being
alienated a bit
um with you know how much softer you
know boot camps and entry to military
service actually is it's like anyone can
join now
[Music]
we've all seen the the war movies
and we you know played the video games
and everything and you know once the
time comes where we're actually
considering joining we're all thinking
the same thing like is it really worth
joining and putting our life on the line
for
ideologies to protect ideologies that we
don't agree with
[Music]